problema número 17 y expresión muestra
la factorización completa de 2x cuadrada
menos 147 veamos el 147 es un número
extraño vamos a ver si podemos
factorizar lo definitivamente no es
divisible entre 12 pues 12 llega hasta
144 veamos indivisiblemente 3 1 4557 es
12 y 12 es divisible entre 3
no sé si conocían esto solo se suman los
dígitos y si el resultado es divisible
en 3
entonces todo el número es divisible
entre 3 147 es divisible entre 3 por
ejemplo 147 lo escribimos acá y lo vamos
a dividir entre 3
nos dan
3 x 4 12 14 12 2 bajamos el 7 y 9 por 3
27 va a ser una dirección exacta 27
menos 27 es igual a 0 y si actualizamos
el 3 de esto nos va a quedar 3 por 4 que
si esto es por 4 12 4 x al cuadrado
menos 49 y lo que está en el paréntesis
tiene la pinta de ser algo como a
cuadrado menos b cuadrado donde a es 2 x
2 x
y ve es 77 por 749 así que esto lo puedo
escribir como 3 por 2 x más 77 x
2x menos 7
y esta es la opción d
muy bien siguiente problema nos piden
que resolvamos esto cuando se agrega no
suman fracciones hay que encontrar el
común denominador en este caso hay que
encontrar un factor común en ambos
polinomios y sospecho que el x 5 es un
factor del otro polinomio bueno qué par
de números al multiplicar se dan menos
10 y al sumar se dan 3
vamos a ver esta parte de acá que polino
me da esto
si yo multiplico x 5 por x2 x + 5 por x
6 / todo esto y tenemos pues este otro
polinomio que vamos a sumar x + 3 x + 3
/ x 5
y la suma de estos dos va a ser igual a
nuestro denominador común que es x 5 x
x2
este x + 3 ya tiene el x 5 aquí abajo
les falta multiplicarse por x2
hacemos esa multiplicación y vamos a
tener x cuadrado menos 2 x + 3 x menos 6
más del 6 que tenemos acá
6 vamos a simplificar esto menos 6 se va
con este más 6
- 2 x 3 x me va a quedar x esto es igual
a x cuadrada + 2 en el numerador
y por lo que veo las respuestas están
con el denominador extendido aquí en
este formato así que no podemos dejar x
cuadrada
más 3x
- 10
y esta es la opción
el siguiente problema número 19 cuál es
la forma simplificada de 3 a cuadrada de
kubica se al menos 2 entre al menos 1 b
cuadradas todo eso al cubo entremos
directo simplificar tenemos 3 a cuadrado
por b al cubo
porsche a la menos 2
/ a menos 1 al cubo va a ser igual a al
menos 3 b al cuadrado al cubo va a ser
igual a b a las 6
al cubo pues así quedarse al cubo
ahora esto es igual a 3 por a elevada a
la 2 - este exponente de aquí abajo
menos 3
por b al cubo menos el exponente de
abajo
por si al menos dos que aquí no sea la
menos 2
- el exponente de abajo que es 3 - 3
esto es igual a 3 a 2 - menos 3 es igual
a 5 por b 3 menos 6 - 3 - 3
2 - 3 es igual a menos 5 sea la menos 5
esto lo podemos expresar también como 3
a la quinta entre b kubica por c a la
quinta
y esta es mi opción
siguiente problema
número 20 que es 20 x a la menos 4 entre
27 cuadrada entre 8 x menos 3 entre 15 y
25 cuando dividimos entre una fracción
es lo mismo que multiplicar por su
inverso y me quiere deshacer de este
signo de división
voy a tener 20 x
al menos 4 entre 27 y cuadradas
el inverso de este es 15 y al menos 5 /
8x a la menos atrás
vamos a simplificar 15 entre 35 y un 27
entre 39 20 entre 45 y ocho entre 4 es
dos y recuerden que cuando tenemos
multiplicaciones entre fracciones
multiplicamos numerador con numerador y
denominador con denominador por lo que
nos queda que esto es igual a 5 x a la
menos 4
por 5 1 al menos 5
entre 9 y cuadrada por 2 x a la menos 3
esto es igual a 5 por 5 25
entre 9 por 2 18 x al menos 4 menos -3
que este exponente de acá por qué a la
menos 5 -2 esto es igual a 25 25
/ 18 - 43 menos 1 así que esta x quedará
aquí abajo con el exponente positivo
menos cinco menos dos es menos siete por
lo que te queda ya a las siete pero aquí
abajo un dividiendo que es mi opción d
y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo